the impression that has occasionally arisen
that there is a closed coalition
and germany is standing in the way this
impression is wrong
there are many allies many allies
who say we share the view which
i have not explained again today
there are good reasons for
delivering the good  Reasons against it
and in view of the overall situation of a
war that
has been going on for almost a year now, all the pros and cons have to be
weighed up very carefully, we ca
n't all say today when a
decision will be made and what the decision
will be about Leopard tanks, I
certainly don't know why
talking just  about delivering anything
to anybody this is in you kind of
measure so we have to be carefully
because we are the Duty 2 to look
carefully and intensively or what might
be the consequences for anybody inside
we will make our decisions
like that just like that this is  nothing
shoes
Priority number 1 is air defense air defense
air defense
especially with regard to ammunition that is
why this will have to
take top priority
we for our part will deliver
a
fire unit of the Patriot anti-aircraft missile system
to the Ukraine to strengthen air defense,
these will also be delivered at the same time as our US partners
Voted